we have finally seen some gameplay of
halo infinite
despite some grumbling about the visuals
it's looking like a pretty good halo
game
there's a lot of details in the 8 minute
demo some
obvious and others more subtle in this
video we've gone ahead and compiled all
of that information
for you into one super video let's get
to it
let's start with the story the opening
of the demo sets the time frame on may
28th
2560 160
days after we lost this event is
referred to
several times but the game is staying
cagey on what exactly this
is for reference the events of halo 5
take place and
end in october of 2558
and the events of halo wars 2 take place
in 2559
343 has stated that infinite is set to
be the conclusion
of the forerunner saga the storyline
that started all the way back in halo 4.
it's also going to set the path for
future halo stories
the main villains of the game are the
banished a splinter group that broke off
from the covenant long ago
they were the main antagonists of halo
wars 2 and
no you do not need to play that game in
order to understand the story of
infinite according to 343
the leader of the banished and infinite
is warchief as
char charm as charm and go ahead and say
that
he has taken over the banished in
replace of atriox the villain from halo
wars 2.
he and his banished have taken control
of a halo ring presumably installation
0-4 the ring from combat evolved
and is seemingly trying to repair it in
his big speech at the end of the demo
he mentioned the harbinger someone who
shares the same goal as the banished
we don't know who this is and 343 isn't
telling
but come on probably cortana last thing
of note i thought was interesting
is ign asked 343 how much master chief
talks in this one
and the answer was somewhere in between
the mostly silent chief of the original
trilogy
wait here and the very chatty chief of
halo 4
and 5. let's talk how halo infinite is
structured because it's by far the most
intriguing aspect
and also still the least clear 343 has
said the game still has a story
progression of a beginning a middle
and an end within the game there are
these large open spaces which have
optional missions and
places to explore how much of the game
is
like this is unclear they have stated
that you can return to previous areas to
explore places you missed though
as a part of this new open level design
343 has stated that the game is
several times larger than our last two
campaigns put together
which will make it the largest halo game
to date
to help navigate these large
environments is the brand new map
in it you can do basic map stuff like
set waypoints and
check which missions are available you
know basic video game things
in gameplay chief has a scan pulse
ability which shows nearby objects of
interest and objectives
interestingly these appear to have a
difficulty associated with them
in this objective to take out gun
battery west you can see the symbol the
franchise traditionally uses for
normal difficulty in the menu we also
see an
upgrade tab but we don't actually get to
see what it looks like
343 has stated that the upgrades are
referring to the new equipment master
chief picks up over the game
they assure players that there is no
experience meter or experience based
skill tree
speaking of equipment the demo featured
what is probably the biggest change to
master chief's arsenal
a grappling hook known as the grapple
shot
it seems to be a pretty versatile piece
of equipment letting you close the gap
on enemies traverse the environment
and pick up objects like fusion coils
that you can then throw
i'm super curious if you can use this to
pick up weapons off the ground
the other equipment shown is the drop
wall a front-facing energy wall that
functions a lot like halo 3's bubble
shield
except that chief can shoot through his
side equipment like the drop wall appear
to be a one-time use while the grapple
shot has a cooldown
let's round it out by getting super
specific and talking weapons
on the unsc side we got the brand new vk
78 commando a full auto machine gun with
a scope that's described as
good for mid long range this seems to
fill the role usually meant for
something like the battle rifle
but don't worry that gun also is making
a return
we see it for half a second in the
trailer and its design is in line with
the classic halo 2 look
we also have the cqs48 bulldog
a 12 gauge riot shotgun that is
apparently replacing the classic halo
shotgun
of course the assault rifle returns
sporting a look closer in design to the
version seen in halo reach
this one is the ma40ar while the reach
one was the ma37
so it does indeed appear to be an
upgrade from the original the pistol
shown is the mk50 sidekick which gives
off strong halo 2 vibes and
doesn't appear to have a scope in fact
it's worth pointing out that we don't
see
any aiming down sights on weapons that
don't have scopes
so it seems that 343 has gone back on
the design decision
to give all weapons ads like they did in
halo 5.
on the covenant side there's the pulse
carbine a new weapon that seems like a
fusion of the plasma rifle and the
covenant carbine
the plasma pistols there but we don't
get to see in action and there's a brief
look at the energy sword in a new
trailer
the return of brutes means the return of
brute weapons like the spike grenade
there's the mangler a slow but powerful
pistol that reminds me a lot of the
mauler shotgun from halo 3.
and last there is the ravanger a new
three round burst weapon that is energy
based with a percent meter
and vent forward loading 343 has said
that banished weapons with blades on
them
will do more melee damage than typical
melee the game will run at 60fps
although 343 has only been referring to
the series x when talking about it
so we're not really sure if it'll reach
that on say the standard xbox one
it will also run up to 4k on the series
x
they've also stated that next gen
features like ray tracing will be coming
post launch as a free
update now the demo has been getting
some flack for its visuals
xbox marketing general manager aaron
greenberg has said in an interview with
inside gaming
that the game is still a work in
progress and is confident the game will
continue to get
better and better in the coming months
they've also confirmed a pc version
like with the master chief collection
you can get it on windows 10 the xbox
game pass app and yes
even steam 343 has said there is a
dedicated team focusing on the pc
version
in order to make sure it's the best it
can possibly be
343 is saving a big multiplayer reveal
for later on but we did get a few
tidbits
after the backlash from halo 5's lack of
split screen
343 has confirmed that infinite will
feature two-player split screen
co-op on the pvp end the grapple shot
will show up but as a pickup
not a permanent ability also there was a
rumor that the game wouldn't launch with
multiplayer
but that has been confirmed as false
however if you were hoping for a public
beta
which was originally planned 343 has
gone back on that
and can't make any promises and finally
343 has said that halo infinite
is a platform for the future of the
series but
what exactly does that mean instead of
another box sequel future halo stories
will be added onto infinite
and they've built the game and their
tech around this idea
343 has stressed that halo infinite
isn't a live service game like destiny
and this idea is more like how they've
been continually adding to the master
chief collection over the years
and that is every little detail we now
know of halo infinite
the game is scheduled for a fall release
with the xbox series x
which is coming up really fast expect a
lot more details on halo infinite in the
coming months
so come back to gamespot for all the
latest information thanks for watching
you